anyone with a blue suitcase you may now
board finally no not you sir not me this
is a blue suitcase that's a blue
computer bag so you're not you're not
gonna let me on then
damn it damn it damn it damn it God damn
it
anyone who doesn't seem cranky
hello this is Gavin hi Gavin my name is
Colin Valenti I'm calling from Master
Travel Incorporated I'll tell you about
next 11 time off exclusive Las Vegas
getaway I have a few minutes of your
time to tell you about this new package
you know what I would love to but I just
don't have the time
hello
College
just like that for a million minutes
this is Colin valenci Master Travel
Incorporated I may be a service uh hi
Karen Valenti my name is uh Gavin I
think we just talked uh did we get
disconnected
yeah no I mean yeah I hung up on you
why would you do that
I mean are you even are you even allowed
to do that
what were you going to buy the Las Vegas
package well I mean probably not but
that's not the point the point
[Music]
this is Colin yeah Valenti listen um I
don't know what crawled up your ass and
set up shop there but you don't get to
hang up oh
[Music]
my God
what the do you want what is your
deal huh
um you don't want the biggest package so
I don't want to talk it's just a favor
wasting our time stop
stop why shouldn't I yeah what if I
wanted the Vegas package you know what I
want the Vegas package
sure you do
your mother
oh my God you son of a
come on man Let It Go new man ew I want
five
packages right now you know what you
know what my wallet this is my credit
card number right here okay this
is my credit card number is zero zero
seven four five four zero three zero
zero nine eight decoration date is 12 20
and then and then we have a security
number is zero eight four so run the
damn card right now right now you run it
right now
thank you for your business
well I hope you learned
these new call scripts are really great
yeah I know right
do you want Kathy
[Music]
Hello magazine this is speaking hello
Riaz I would like to report an item
which I ordered that arrived Broken
Window Sanders Mockingbird Lane that's
right I am showing the last item that
you've received is the Superman bed with
the mattress of solitude that's the one
ordered it from a son for his birthday
but I cannot give it to him like this
and I'm pretty darn tooting pissed about
it
I will start processing your reorder
right now with you on the line okay I
Ain't Mad At You Rios it's just the
system I know okay thank you for
understanding sir
kids eh huh
oh okay well yeah I just got the one
myself
had sex with a woman and everything to
get them how long is this gonna what is
your son's name
oh uh
um
tempeh
pretty much Stimpy I have boys too I'll
tell you sometimes I can be a real
couple of universe so you're preaching
of a choir Ria Stimpy don't you give me
that look you're gonna get it when your
mama comes home oh man sounds like your
wife is on Wheels you got that
straight riyaz
hot little biscuit though name's Claire
body 10 face 10 so pretty much hit that
every night
sexually
anyway what's holding up though one more
minute and uh how old is her son
15.
it is a Superman bed
enjoy it while you still can
he'll grow out of the toys any day now
they all do
okay he starts hooking up with the girls
he'll forget all about that Superman and
Spider-Man stuff pretty much seems like
how it would happen
maybe then he'll stop bothering me with
all those stupid little facts about how
those characters you just named are
clearly from two distinct and separate
universes sadly some people never move
on sad I got a better word for you
pathetic I
that's okay hey I called them locks I
see some reals and I don't tolerate
nerds in fact let me nip this in the bud
real quick stimp it stick
in here well I didn't mean to where you
are with your brown body and your creepy
ass face no more sweets for you cause
you're never gonna get laid if you keep
eating sweets
hey all these figurines and toys you got
around the house we're throwing them in
the trash because they're not real
people Stimpy they're not real people so
stop being so lonely stop pins so lonely
yeah
well
and this is none of my business of
course
but I was wondering if your son would
like to talk to someone
out simply just jumped out the window oh
my god oh he killed himself why they do
it it must have been my fault no it
wasn't yes it was I'm gonna call the
cops don't you dare cancel that reorder
it's the only thing I'll have to
remember him bye
good morning ladies and gentlemen we are
about to begin boarding South Northern
Airlines flight 34 to Grand Rapids
reporting group one I'm an important
group one excuse me I'm in boarding
group one
and we would like to begin pre-boarding
with our first class passenger
passengers first class passengers all
next are business class passengers may
now board
okay now we would like to welcome our
Regal Alliance Elite members Regal
Alliance Elite members
okay now all passengers with children
anyone with small children you mean
bored now
okay we would like to continue boarding
with uniformed military personnel what
why kids
thank you for your service thank you so
much for your service God bless you
thank you for your service thank you for
your service
all right people in wheelchairs
any priests nuns rabbis imans what why
do they get special treatment assalamu
alaikum I've never
that's typical any old people in
wheelchairs with babies
all right
any old religious people with military
babies what's a military
for your service
Jason Schwartzman
anyone with a blue suitcase you may now
board finally no not you sir not me this
is a blue suitcase that's a blue
computer bag so you're not you're not
gonna let me on then
damn it damn it damn it damn it God damn
it
anyone who doesn't seem cranky
drunk people it will now be boarding any
drunk people
nope it's my man sir
yes
hello
oh hey Christian
yeah
totally
well you have your favorites and I have
my favorites
okay
call you later
ciao
sporting group Juan
[Music]
thank you
everyone
feels fine
[Applause]
let's wrap it up people
morning group one over here
to the boarding group one ah
[Music]
but you know